we'll go through all of our different
brands and i look at how much stress
does this one bring me and how much
income does it bring us and we evaluate
it's like well
life is too short like let's get rid of
that even if it's the one that people
kind of know you for sometimes you
take a niche so far and you're sick of
it and you hate it and it's doing okay
but you just you hate it so much and
it's not making you enough money and
it's okay to walk away from it
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show
and here on the podcast we release a
brand new episode every single tuesday
to help you grow your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business so make sure you're
subscribed wherever you like to consume
this content on now today is a special
episode because we get to bring someone
who has literally changed our lives onto
the show i'm talking none other than
chalene johnson you know way back about
six seven years ago shawn and i both
were students of chalene's marketing
impact academy it was the catalyst to
what changed our lives into
understanding more than just the social
media side of things more than just the
video side of things that sean knew but
really the impact of laying the right
foundation in your business and i'm
excited to bring not just this episode
to you but to also let you know about
what we are calling
thinkbusinessweek.com chalene is hosting
a free week teaching you all about the
foundations of building your online
business it's going to be one incredible
week that you do not want to miss so you
can register for her free class at
thinkbusinessweek.com now today on the
show chalene and sean are talking all
about should you be niching down now if
you're anything like me i am a
multi-passionate entrepreneur i have a
lot of different hobbies and a lot of
different things that i want to talk
about but chalene is the queen when it
comes to understanding how to stay
focused online what is incredible is
that even as a multi-passionate
entrepreneur you're gonna learn when
should you be scaling when should you
stay focused and how do you actually
create an empire online okay that might
be a little much but we're talking all
about how to niche down and how to know
the right niche for you so let's get
into today's featured conversation
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm excited for our feature conversation
today with chalene johnson who's gonna
be at grow with video live 2022 but if
you're just meeting her she is a new
york times best-selling author the
founder of the marketing impact academy
fitness celebrity creating programs like
piyo she's crushed it in beachbody and
is known all around the world and also
has created instagram
coaching products like insta clubhub
she's uh passionate about helping people
get their fitness and their diet right
with
products and programs like the 131
method she's got a whole bunch of
instagram accounts you've never heard
about called feature accounts she's one
of the most influential entrepreneur
voices and mentors in my life personally
her and brett johnson uh not just
business but also family life leading
your team but today i'm excited to talk
all about the idea of niching down and
when you're a multi-passionate
entrepreneur when you're just starting
what do i want to make my youtube
channel about it could be so
overwhelming to think about man niche
down it's constricting it's overwhelming
and there's all these different phases
to it in fact introducing you i i
mentioned 38 things you're doing i don't
know how you did that too like
extemporaneously you really should be on
the news or something
i mean i agree you should start a
youtube channel and you i'm thinking
about starting a video podcast like that
would be uh one of the things but but
chalene talk about it and you help a lot
of people with this because people come
to you and they're like i i love fitness
but i also collect books
and i'm also wondering everything's
crowded and like how do i niche down and
so let's unpack this conversation a
little bit you've been you've been
helping people a long time what are your
thoughts
it's one of the first things i always
say when i start speaking i give that
disclaimer that
i'm going to share with you the best
tips and strategies that you should
employ right now but don't look at my
stuff
for examples of that because i'm in a
different stage and i think so many
people who and you know like people are
coming to mind right now who have huge
followings or big platforms and they're
teaching but they're teaching what
they're doing right now and that doesn't
make any sense because you're at a
different stage i think
there's there are levels and their
stages and at each stage the methodology
that you follow and the strategy that
you need to follow is different
well let's talk about the levels then so
level one
and i'm just starting i'm trying to get
you know a brand new youtube channel a
brand new instagram account um if you're
just starting you're at level one or in
those early levels what is your advice
on niching
you don't have a choice like you have to
be known especially this is true now
more than ever because there's twice as
many people on social media today as
there were 10 years ago you know
and to stand out everybody's following
everybody and no one has the time to
look at everyone's content so whether
you're following 200 or 2 000 people on
instagram or youtube or facebook you're
seeing less than four percent of those
people
and we don't have time to look at and
follow people and get to know the people
who
whenever we
you know stop by and look at their
content we don't know what we're gonna
get you know it might be
one of their many interests then it's
just too confusing and you're not gonna
you're not gonna get them coming back to
see more of fill in the blank because
they don't know what fill in the blank
is so it's really really hard especially
for people who are creative because
people are creative can do anything they
like lots of things they have all these
different interests and if you're
entrepreneurial you're afraid to pick
one because you're like i might pick the
wrong one and if i pick this one what if
this one over here pops so you feel like
well if i just kind of juggle them all
up in the air i only have five i only
have five interests um and you could do
that like maybe even
seven eight years ago but not today
if you do it's going to take you 10
times longer to be known
so choosing a niche niching down
choosing a topic niching down depending
on how you want to say it um is is so
critical for getting noticed and sending
out yeah do you have any advice for
narrowing maybe a listener right now is
like you know there's three things
how do i pick one and i feel like all
three are great
we always have to look at the
opportunity right so when i had to do
this myself i was um doing so many
different things i was wanted to be
known as writing
how to start personal training business
i was working as a paralegal i was
trying to teach women how to start
businesses at home
i was trying to do like mini seminars in
hotel like i was doing all the million
different things
and
one of those things i was interested in
was fitness
i also saw that at that moment like
there there was a huge opportunity like
there's this window where there's no one
doing kind of what i was doing
and so i saw that opportunity and that
when you're looking at like the myriad
of things you're interested in you have
to look at the one like okay what's the
one that there's a real opportunity
because no one or fewer people someone's
doing it but fewer people are doing it
so is there an opportunity financially
and then the other questions you have to
ask yourself is this something
if you just made a list right now of the
things that you could speak endlessly
about you're the know-it-all if you hear
someone else talking about you almost
have to like interrupt and say i've got
to tell you guys this because and so
you're passionate about it you research
about it you're you're excited about it
and there might be five things that fall
into that category but what are what are
like the one or two where it's like and
there's a financial opportunity or an
opportunity uh to fulfill a a gap where
there's not enough people talking about
it or talking about in the way that you
are yeah and then you just gotta bite
the bullet and freaking do it yep nobody
wants to
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
so you niche down you you bite the
bullet you freaking do it and and then
you start to get momentum when do you
would you say
uh
you would say this is good enough
momentum to broaden out here's one of
the biggest questions we get
oh great you know i've posted 50 videos
now and it's working i got 3 000
subscribers 12 000 i got some money
coming in um maybe i'm part-time at my
job now but i've got some site income
coming in and
i'm already thinking about doing
something else i want to start a second
channel now i want to start a third
channel now and and when would you say
how long you should keep your focus how
long before expanding a lot of people
that's a big question can i start a
second channel sean you know can i start
a third channel and i'm like well is the
one
really got momentum what do you think
that that how long do you stay niche for
you too again you're doing a lot of
things today
but you just start that way correct and
so
there's maybe not a prescriptive length
of time but there's a feeling okay so i
would say that you know there isn't
exactly there's no prescriptive length
of time because you might have insane
growth and do all the things that
necessitate or make it possible for you
to expand into other areas
but i would say for most people you have
to say is this what people know me for
so like when i'm talking about sean
kennel is this what they're
saying about me and i don't have to
constantly remind people what i do when
they're talking about a specific niche
does my name constantly come up
that's and that takes a lot of time and
patience that's not going to happen in
three months for most people it's just
not it's not even gonna happen in a year
for most people if i'm being honest
um that's number one number two
is
i always tell people you're gonna you're
gonna be so sick of it that's when you
not you're still interested in it it's
like you're like i hate this
so much i have to get away for a minute
that's when you know like it's probably
time that's another kind of measure and
then lastly
that you can if you can walk away from
it and outsource the management of it
does it continue to grow does it
continue to do well or do you still have
to be invested 100
an example this would be fitness so for
me when i decided oh i got to bite the
bullet and just niche exclusively in
fitness i did so for probably eight
years
um that was all my social media was that
was all that i you know talked and did
um and then it got to a point where
number one i was sick of it i was dying
for that entire time to talk about all
the other niches
it got to a place where financially it
could be managed where there was income
still coming in and i didn't have to
be the face of that and that's where
those other accounts come in
so if you've got the bandwidth which
most people don't so i even hate to
bring this up
but
if you're at a stage financially from
that single niche and you know
the importance of bringing on team
members who can manage that for you
then you have
it's a little safer for you to branch
off into another niche so for me that
means other accounts so we have a niche
account for each and every one of my
brands so that my personal accounts
which you know on instagram yeah
speaking specifically
i can talk about all the things yeah but
i do have niched accounts for all the
other separate brands super powerful
okay so
that's kind of now stage one maybe stage
two and eventually you get to a place
where in a way you kind of go into a
whole other vertical because knowing
your story you're known in
obviously fitness you say eight years
um you're here at this event about to
speak on instagram and your instagram
expert you're also known as a they've
been listening to an entrepreneur and
these different places as one of the top
marketing experts or social marketing so
marketing is different than fitness
that's like an entirely different
vertical
for someone watching that's like i want
to add on or i'm thinking about leaving
that thing
and then rebuilding and when is that any
tips for that because again
someone's comparing themselves to
chalene johnson they go well
why can't i start with 14 things yeah
yeah i i love marketing and i want to do
fit and i want to be an expert in all of
it so what is your advice
you kind of already touched on it
multiple accounts but now in the level
you're at maybe some advice for me as
well and anyone who can kind of draft
off that in our podcast community
is like you kind of want to be i want
i'm very passionate about leadership
i'm
youtube secrets second edition the book
is about to come out and i'm questioning
should my next book still be on youtube
to stay niched or
i i want to talk about leadership i want
to talk faith and leadership either i
got this oh i got that okay so you can
see where i'm going oh my god yes
okay so
it has to make
sense to your audience i think so
because us you're not for most people
you don't have to start over from
scratch i'd have to start over from
scratch and build a completely new
audience with marketing there's a very
small faction of my fitness audience who
wanted to understand
marketing and so that through line is
the reason why i was successful in
fitness isn't because i knew the most
about fitness or even that was my
greatest passion is because i really
understood solving a problem and that's
marketing and it is because of my
prowess and my understanding and my
study and my passion for marketing that
i was able to
use that to launch a fitness business
and a journal business and uh an
instagram coaching business like that's
the through line so to circle back to
your own it makes sense for people to
say the reason why my youtube business
has been successful isn't because i know
the most about youtube
it's because of building this incredible
team and that starts with leadership
yeah and so it's like kind of making
helping people to understand how it
makes sense it's that person who's a
chiropractor but now what they really
want to do is help people
heal with food and so they want to go
into nutrition and
whole food diet etc so it's making that
connection saying you know i i realized
i could adjust people every week
but my true passion was helping people
understand
that it's a whole person process so as
long as it makes sense to your audience
that's number one about
you know how to do that and then
you
you really have to commit to your new
niche which is why i don't recommend
starting one until financially
you can turn it over to someone else to
help you run it so you want there to be
a bridge there there's a connection to
it there's a bridge there it's an
adjacency to what you're probably
already doing and and then once it's
automated and can be automated and then
to a point once you're in that phase
have you found that there's times when
maybe you have to go back
and ramp it up again yeah or actually
you know maybe a certain season team
shifts around a little bit
i have you been in seasons ever of
overwhelm where you're like wow i'm now
three steps out and and you're kind of
juggling a couple things um because even
automation
maybe may or may not be perfect so
what's the healthiest time you know
so i think you and i both agree on this
like it has to be about my mental state
right and it's never about the money um
but that gets in your ego right where
you're like oh man
i've got to be doing all these things
and if i don't give that all this
attention and this all that attention
then i'm going to be
making less money and it's for me that's
never worth it but there have been times
where i have had to say like
of all these things we're doing this and
we do this you know once at least
once a quarter i mean at least once a
year sometimes once a quarter where
we'll go through all of our different
brands and i look at how much stress
does this one bring me and how much
income does it bring us and we evaluate
it's like well
life is too short like let's get rid of
that even if it's the one that people
kind of know you for i also wanted to
mention
sometimes you
take a niche so far and you're sick of
it and you hate it
and it's doing okay but you just you
hate it so much and it's not making you
enough money and it's okay to walk away
from it
it doesn't have to go in your tombstone
that's good i also think when it comes
to niche like sometimes you can't just
plan these things they god drops things
in your life where you're like i have to
talk about this like jeremiah says it's
burning in my body yes like and so you
feel it that's probably a good test too
there's a couple things but one is
burning like yeah you're pat and you
probably want to you got to follow the
flame yeah so if you you know i teach
instagram i teach people like you've got
to stay unniche to your feed post but
then they go and look at my instagram
and they're like you're all over the
place sure but i'm also i'm not building
a brand with my personal instagram or a
business yeah um and so being chalene
johnson with your personal which is a
matter of clarity of what are you doing
with the account
and what i'm doing with the account for
me is i'm helping people get through
whatever it is
you know god placed in my path recently
it's i've just been
uh
putting all my passion and interest and
heart into being an advocate for patient
patients rights yeah and um
what does that do with any of my
businesses nothing
but i also am now at a stage where
because of my platform i feel an
obligation
to use it in a way that gives people who
don't have a voice of voice and that
doesn't always have to make you money
yeah you know yeah so powerful well
chalene johnson so grateful for you and
um i
of course we have show notes and links
that will take you to her resources i
want to hear some of that in a bit but
i'm curious yeah any kind of book
recommendations for someone wanting
clarity one of my favorites is the one
thing
right i don't know if you're familiar
with that one by gary keller
and
is there any has there been any
resources like that that are top of mind
yes um yeah what is that
so glad you asked um business made
simple okay it's unbelievable by donald
miller yes it is a phenomenal book the
funny thing is i've list i list i don't
read any books i listen to all books
and um i have probably listened to that
audible book uh three times wow i just i
think it's
every mba student should have it every
member of your team should have it i
think we're in a place now where people
can work from home even if they're
working for somebody else you've got to
think of it like it's your own business
because you are a commodity and i just
think he teaches so much about integrity
and
understanding strategy it's just a
powerful book and simple yeah amazing
well we'll definitely link those up and
then chalene if people want to connect
with you follow you what's going on
call my net call me i'll give my cell
phone number and just text me link in
the description yes uh chalene johnson
on instagram shaleenjohnson on instagram
chalene appreciate you coming on the
podcast appreciate you so much and just
really want to acknowledge your
influence not just in my life but in our
community's life so thanks again
appreciate
you
well i hope that that was an inspiring
conversation for you and i want to know
what are your next steps that you need
to take what is the action step that is
right for you do you need to niche down
are you ready to expand or are you ready
to sign up for chalene's free business
week at
thinkbusinessweek.com i'm excited for
the think community to be learning from
someone who has literally changed my
life and i hope that during this free
week of content that you can see what
your next step would be with chalene as
well now here on the podcast we love to
read your reviews it helps us so much
when you rate and review the podcast
over on apple itunes no that's not where
you do it apple podcast when you rate
and review the podcast over there it
helps this show get out to more people
and people actually read the reviews of
shows before they invest time in
listening to it so you being one of our
think fam members it means so much to us
when you actually rate and review the
podcast and sometimes every episode
actually we read one of those on the
show today it comes from sfm245
they said these guys are so informative
i'm glad to see the think media team
embracing the longer forum content i
actually enjoy listening to them
breaking down their data and their
findings in a podcast narrative because
i can tell they do not cut anything out
or at least not that much with the way
youtube is i understand why some videos
need to be trimmed in order to get the
desired views here i don't have to worry
about that i just feel like i'm getting
an authentic take on the topics they're
discussing comparing to a short youtube
video keep up the good work thank you so
much for those encouraging words and
yeah that's actually why we started the
podcast was because we wanted to have
deeper conversations we wanted to bring
our guest expert friends on and talk
about some you know related topics to
what it is to be an online entrepreneur
using video to grow your personal brand
and so thank you for seeing the efforts
we're putting in but thank you for being
a consistent listener here on the show
well thank you again for listening to
today's episode i hope that you join
chalene for her free business week and
we'll catch you in the next episode bye
did you hear that growth video live 2022
is back in person this is your
opportunity to network with like-minded
people just like you to make friendships
to make business partnerships this is
your opportunity to get in the room you
can get your ticket now at
growethvideolive.com they're going so
fast so make sure you get your ticket
right now at growthvideolive.com
[Music]
you